behind the scenes of the Victoria's
Secret Fashion Show Plus Kim K Posen and
nothing but glitter hello friends this
is the daily Deni and as we all still
try to shave off the turkey remains we
ate this past week how's this for
motivation
tonight is the Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show and only ET cameras we're backstage
at the show and Shanghai China and the
night mostly went off without a hitch
just one fall from Chinese model me Z
she wiped it on the catwalk but I got to
say that is the happiest I've ever seen
someone eat it especially in front of
thousands now fellow model Gisele
Oliviera topped her up now other than
that the models were in full form even
for the Angels also pulling mommy duty
as a mom and you your daughters are
watching you are they get inspired also
it's not only about like putting a
larger you not wear much is not about
that it's about working epic and I think
that's the most important thing for my
girls my daughter is back in America and
but she's very excited I told her I'm
like today Dixie I'm doing the show
where I get to wear the wings she was
like how hard is it to be a mom and be
an angel you know Victoria's Secret are
so amazing with us they know we're moms
it's her first priority and then we get
to come do this I remember when I was
pregnant of my son I was on the runway
I'm so happy that she's here and
hopefully she will remember that will
inspire her I'm eating her food and if
she sees that I'm eating something
so I was like it was like plenty you
have this show coming out of like now
for mama Alessandra the show marks her
final strut down the Victoria's Secret
catalog after seventeen angelic years
tonight you guys can also enjoy
performances by Harry Styles and Miguel
when the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show
airs tonight on CBS now someone else who
has showing off a lot to skin kim
kardashian the 37 year old reality star
took to instagram on monday to promote
her new line of k'kaw beauty products
posing in the buff folks drenched in
gold glitter silver locks in a high
ponytail and a very strategically placed
arm the line of highlighters and gloss
is called ultra light beam it's a nod to
husband Kanye West's song of his life of
Pablo album it should come as no
surprise Kim is inspired by her hubby in
fact she told us she took his input
seriously when deciding on her crystal
gardenia fragrances loved to share one
big bathroom cuz it's when we get to
talk and collaborate and our lives are
so busy and so I was testing out a
fragrance he walked by me in the
bathroom and was like what is that I
don't like that and I was like this is
one I was debating between and this is
the one I wasn't you know liking and he
confirmed it and then he said you know
what I really always want to smell your
fragrance cuz if you if this is the one
and I don't like it like this it'll be a
problem I think she should marry that
man speaking of marriage the countdown
to the Royal Wedding is officially on in
fact Prince Harry and Megan Marco hasta
a date the Kensington Palace announced
today that the wedding will take place
at the st. George Chapel at Windsor
Castle May 28 and guys this place is so
unreal just look at the inside and get
this et has also learned that Megan will
be baptized and confirmed before her big
walk down the aisle and she plans to
become a UK citizen that my friends is a
real ride-or-die alright that's it for
today thank you to my ride or dies for
watching today we'll be back tomorrow
for another episode so make sure you
guys have your notifications on and I'll
see you then good bye
you